this makes me insane okay I'm talking
about being called crazy oh right you're
me do you hate when a man calls you this
show right and does it actually just end
up making you even more crazy hundred
percent right ladies just getting cold
crazy drive you crazy what it's almost
like when a guy tells you are you is it
that time of the month and you're like
Travis absolutely tried it right it's so
rude I'm worse
calm down there's a major difference
between two different kinds of crazies
like what your girl is like girl you're
so crazy
yeah that's different a man calling you
crazy and I've said this before any time
a man has told me go my ex-girlfriend
she's crazy all I say to them is what
did you do right to make her a crazy men
it's unacceptable for you to call them
crazy we don't usually do something to
make oh yeah crap
however wait a minute y'all wait a
minute wait a minute wait a minute if
I'm honest
hmm I think all girls have a little bit
of crazy in them I think it's just a
degree of crazy and then they take I'm
crazy
oh right here make us a mark here and
sometimes it's not the man that makes
you a little more crazy sometimes it's
that you haven't eaten in the last
couple hours they have a month that you
are pregnant with a 10-pound baby tegus
fear and you don't like yes that they
don't you you don't caught they behind
doing something okay
Tamar you say this sometimes do like if
a guy is almost too good if you really
like this man I'm gonna cause you to be
a little lose them like I thought that
you guys look crazy when I like somebody
so much that you stare at the phone
waiting for sure for them to call you
and you're watching yourself do that and
you're like God he's make me crazy
because you see how amazing he is you
assume everyone else thinks he's amazing
too
[Music]
or you just think he's like too good to
be true so then you make yourself great
you made yourself go crazy right yeah
because I think of certain things like
yeah you know what he ain't that what do
you think he's gonna find out and you go
crazy
which makes me to ask just crazy no
crazy absolutely
okay you know so we know a game
recognize game would you consider
yourself crazy no not at all absolutely
sane 200-person like I feel like it
first of all if you don't have nothing
to hide you leave your phone now I can
look through your phone I believe in
check that is looking yes take my
Czechoslovakia I will check it all make
you crazy they just make you smart
[Music]
these broads are goofy apparently some
men out there you know who you are you
think that PMS is something that we make
up as an excuse for our bad mood tell a
girl's dad
so personal letter to you men out there
dear men PMS is real yes so for a few
days each month don't mess with us
yeah I was with you yes PMS is real not
for all women there are some people that
is slight there's some people that it's
heavy
now how they react to or moans I was
with you on that until you said don't
mess with no you're not a child and if
you're in a relationship with someone
we're gonna deal with it together you're
not a child you're not like some kind of
kid don't mess with me you know that it
doesn't give you an excuse to act as it
gives you a reason without an excuse so
check yourself before you wreck yourself
that's done please stop it
we know you on it you just want to go
even harder visit us right you can be
argue and you have a valid point and
it's always when you have a valid will
win an argument right yeah [ __ ] you did
not clean up your side yes I did Sam I
moved it no you did not you on your
period a yeah you try me crazy yeah I
feel like men use that all the time even
in the workplace oh yeah like I've heard
people say like my boss totally like
because they say women are emotional
obviously women don't want to be you
know stereotyped as emotional especially
in the workplace right and to say that
because you're a woman you can't handle
your job properly in that they're gonna
blame it on PMS I don't like that really
pisses me off well and I have to say on
this show there are a lot of women in
front of the camera and in bad guys
hammer and we all periods comes with an
influx of hormones it can't affect your
behavior now sometimes in a relationship
if I see that you're acting a certain
way I gotta know if it's something I did
or do I have to tackle things
differently because of the time of the
month we are in when I'm saying that
it's not to piss you off why don't ask
that question but I understand why a guy
would he wants to know
if it's something I actually did my
rubbing you the wrong way or is it
because of some of the things it could
inform yourself and actually in a
relationship the best thing is to
communicate that so me knowing that it's
just really me wanting to know what is
the situation right now do I have to
watch out or do I have to check on back
what I did that's why we're asking that
I'm not talking about you're at work
doing your thing and one of your
colleagues tells that to you that's just
not supposed to happen because that's
not nobody's business but it is what it
is you're acting irrational at work I'm
not gonna be talking about what's going
on with your pom pom and everything and
stuff because that's gonna get me
reported to HR I'm gonna do what's good
for me too so what I'm gonna be like
okay I'm gonna I'm gonna go by how you
act in a bureau you gonna collect all
the evidence of you acting irrationally
if I have a boss I go to my boss which
is gonna go to your boss and then it's
gonna talk to you that's how you go
about things at office if I go straight
at you even if I'm right in an office
borough even if you're right about
something
the way you're gonna go about it it's
gonna make you or break you so I'm gonna
go I'm gonna abide by the rules of this
office but in your relationship is
really to understand what is the
situation did I actually do something or
everything I do gets on your nerves then
if that's that I'm gonna give you your
space and it's gonna be that every time
I drink cognac
you know our bees will leave me alone
did you just compare cognac and yes I
did you can see the same symptoms in
different people you some people gonna
cry some people are gonna get aggressive
some people are gonna get ticked off
about different things now it's not an
excuse it's never gonna be an excuse and
I know it's hard I don't know how bad it
is because I can never experience it but
after that a if it's irrational it's
irrational what I can give to the people
as an advice like if you're in
relationship and something in rationale
is happening yo hold them accountable
tell them what's going on you're doing
this this this and that and that that
doesn't make any sense you have to have
this discussion these discussions are
not easy they're not but you have to
have them that's how you're gonna be
able to grow you have to have these
conversations that it is a real thing
but me asking you what's going on I want
to know where
put myself that's it in the relationship
I believe that the man can ask don't
like it is you good I think it's
interesting that you know once a month
you guys want this space opened up to
you where you are irrational you act all
crazy or whatever it is that you guys do
and you want to be able to express that
but if men in turn express how you're
making them feel or what they're
perceiving they're the devil so you guys
have a biological experience and it
makes you act all kinds of way and say
all kinds of stuff but if we acknowledge
that we're like this is what we're
seeing or expression unacceptable that
to me is a little strange if I can't
have a conversation with the person I'm
with I can't be with that person if I
can't go to my girl and be like um
that's a bit crazy because of this and
that and that and that if I can't have
back over these I cannot be with that
person I don't that's not even a thing
you ever get back and look we're not
talking about when dudes dismiss
everything the girl does as crazy we're
not talking about that
there's some dudes you take it too far
there's a middle ground but there's a
gaslighting aspect of it right
then there's a middle ground where
sometimes y'all are actually acting
crazy and then there's other time where
people don't ask any questions and
everything just happens right somewhere
in the middle it does make sense to be
like hey this behavior is a little
strange but what's going on and just
because you don't like how it's worn it
doesn't mean that it's not valid the
same way just because we don't like how
your behavior doesn't mean that you
don't have a valid reason to behave that
way right so a little bit of
understanding from both sides we'll all
do us some good
I just wish these girls were more
self-aware and realize how this sounded
in that moment for them to sit at that
table and say all this stuff and not
realize how they sound to me blew my
mind I'm empathetic enough to understand
that okay y'all are dealing with
something that's real that I can't
understand I can understand that never
you could never you could try you could
never not viscerally but I could
understand it there's something
happening to accept this you taking a
lot of stirrers I'm saying that if you
take series you're gonna have PMS like
sometimes at some point yeah like but
you're never gonna understand them
you're never gonna understand
cuz you're not a woman can you give
birth are you calling me crazy
yeah yeah right now I'll show you crazy
oh yeah I'll jump off a cliff and I'll
show you crazy we have a bridge right
there yeah and just when you think it's
done it's not I'll park my car throw
away the car keys and I'll rip your head
off and I'll wash with a pack of popcorn
and then I'll jump off the bridge
meaning idiot I bet that reference
window right over your head peanut-head
but anyway that's it for today's we
don't let us know what you think we want
to hear your thoughts leave it in the
comments below
[Music]